et parlant de transport en commun dès le
mois prochain les usagers du métro
devront ce pas assez le servait sur la
ligne jaune qui relie la rive sud durant
les fins de semaine et ce pendant
plusieurs semaines des travaux pour
réparer les structures en béton les
infiltrations d'eau qui sont entrepris
et pour montrer l'ampleur de la tâche la
société de transport de montréal a
convié les journalistes
la nuit dernière françois korber si les
métros ne roule pas 24 heures sur 24 à
montréal c'est que la nuit tu es que le
dernier train passe une fourmilière
d'employer ce mot travail
l'installation d'écrans ajustement des
rails coulage de béton mais ici sur la
ligne jaune entre montréal et longueuil
des travaux d'une ampleur beaucoup plus
grande pour voir s'il met donc en
hommage et lire ses infiltrations d'eau
la stm a décidé d'inviter les
journalistes en pleine nuit
question de faire état de la situation
il ne suffit que de quelques minutes
pour constater que le béton s'effrite
que l'eau s'infiltre 4
les grands pieds on a des angles de
faiblesse l'eau s'infiltre puis à la
langue avec les sels minéraux commence à
attaquer le béton pas de danger assure
la société de transport des
infiltrations comme celle là c'est
normal
le béton lui datent des années 60 le
fait que le béton se détériore moment
donné c'est pas ça tombe pas du jour au
lendemain
donc on est ce des dégradations qui
s'observe à la longue on a fait des
inspections et 45 la réfection était
imminent les travaux seront échelonnées
sur 209 nuit et 25 faillites semaine où
il n'y aura aucun métro sur la ligne
jaune des navettes assureront le service
si la stm procède à cette réflexion
maintenant c'est parce qu'elle sait que
les problèmes de circulation à montréal
pourrait augmenter
c'est clair que si pendant les travaux y
dresse produire quoi que ce soit s'il
devait y avoir des problèmes de conches
en plein par exemple ou dans d'autres
infrastructures
on peut très bien très facilement cesser
les travaux même à quelques heures
d'avis une fois que tout sera terminé
la stm espère ne plus avoir à faire de
travaux majeurs dans ce tunnel au moins
pour les 25 prochaines années
si françois qu'hormis radio canada
montréal